during my time at mckinsey i helped in
designing the training programs
for the new consultants in these
training programs communication was
always one of the most important skills
it was common feedback of all the senior
consultants and all the partners
that the number one topic where young
consultants
need training on and where they need to
be developed by the training programs is
how to communicate
effectively how to say the things in the
right
way one of the most fundamental concepts
that we taught in these
training programs is the concept of
top-down communication in this video i'm
going to talk about what
top-down communication is we are jointly
going to work through one
exercise that i trust will really teach
you
how top-down communication works so by
watching this video i trust that you
will build a very important skill set
that will hugely benefit you not only if
you work in consulting
but pretty much in every other role in a
professional context
and probably even in your private life
as well welcome to another coffee break
with
me here on my channel firm learning
if you're new here with this channel i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years in your career but
now without further ado
let's jump into it i will teach you how
to talk like a consultant
and this video will be structured in two
parts first i'm going to talk about what
top down communication actually is
and then second we're going to do an
exercise together to really help you
ingrain this principle in your head so
what
is top-down communication and if you
read all the books and
articles about that you will find out
that there are lots of definitions
many people claiming different things to
be top-down communication
so i really want to simplify it for you
so in my experience what this really
comes down to is
two things namely first in your
communication
to focus on the results to focus on the
content
to only focus on the things that really
matter to your audience and
second always starting your
communication
with the key message with the key result
that you want to communicate to your
audience when people talk about top-down
communication they often also use the
word
pyramid principle the reason why you
talk about a pyramid where you have a
pyramid structure is because you need to
imagine and structure
in your head all the different facts
information all the details that you
want to talk about
in a pyramidal form so at the bottom
there are all the underlying arguments
there are the details
but then based on this fundament you
then draw some conclusions you then draw
some results
and then on the very top is the key
message that you really want to share
and that you really want to talk about
and the main error that many people do
is not starting with this result with
this key message
but rather starting with all the
individual details with all the
little arguments that then your whole
case is composed of
and then only in the very end to then
draw the conclusion from it
so they pretty much turn the pyramid
around and this for many different
reasons
is not considered effective
communication
and if you want to learn more about that
i talked a lot about this in my first
video in communication skills
i will link it somewhere above here for
you if you want to check it out so
that this clarifies what top-down
communication
is but now to make it even more tangible
for you let's deep dive
into a practical example and this was an
exercise that we did a lot with
young consultants that we used a lot at
mckinsey to train
consultants in the organization and you
can imagine the overall setting to be
something like this
you as a consultant sitting in the team
room
just minding your business doing your
work and then suddenly the ceo of the
company or another senior client of the
company or maybe even a partner
is walking into your team room and
asking you hey heinrich
how is it going where do we stand what's
the current status
and this is a question that hits many
people kind of off guard because you
were just in the middle of something
completely adds
and now you're required to in front of a
senior person
really concisely briefly and to the
point
answering such a question of where you
stand with a specific task so now let's
jump into this exercise and let's
imagine you finding yourself in such a
situation
and the context is as follows and i'm
reading from the slide here
so you are working on a market entry
study
and the objective of the study is to
assess
market entry opportunities for a new
product line so the client asks you to
work on that
and of course you could easily also be
just the internal team so not
necessarily consultant but an employee
of the company working on this specific
task and now in order to do that you
conducted interviews with lots of
different internal and external
experts to learn more about this topic
you analyze
lots of data you work with different
departments with the finance department
with the marketing department
probably the preliminary result the
first indication that you have
is that the market entry in france would
be a good
fit and you're basing this result just
based on all these interviews that you
conducted and all these
data analysis that you did and now
indeed the ceo walks in and asks you to
give
a project summary he says hey how is it
going
you work on the market entry project
right what is the status on that
and now the question is how do you
answer to that and now i just want to
take you a moment and ideally just grab
a pen grab a piece of paper
and just jot down a couple of thoughts
on how you would reply to that and of
course if you want you can just briefly
pause the video to do that
okay so i hope you did just exactly that
and now i want to guide you through two
examples so two examples of potential
answers and then let's briefly discuss
what is going well working well with
this example and maybe what isn't so
much
let's start with example number one as a
potential
answer that somebody could have given
and this answer goes as follows
so the last weeks we have been very busy
on the project
first i talked to tom from finance to
get the market data
however when looking at the numbers we
realize that marketing has the better
numbers
with the new marketing data set together
with interviews we conducted we were
able to get a good
overview of the different market
opportunities at the moment it looks
like
france would be a good fit for our
project though this
is still working progress so this could
be an answer and
from my experience this is an answer
that
many people would give in such a
situation so let's just dissect it a bit
what is
special what is characteristic about
this answer and this answer consists of
now stating
all the different steps that you did all
the different steps that you did to come
to this conclusion
you're saying okay first i did that then
i did this then i talked to this guy
then i talked to that guy
so lots of work that i put in i crunched
all these numbers
and in the end there is a specific
result
that we have now and of course now if
you look into this this
is something that you would not consider
top-down communication okay guys this is
not top-down communication but it's the
opposite it's
bottom-up communication because you
start by giving all the details by
giving all the
nitty-gritty facts and steps and
arguments
this is communication that is based on
the process
it's based on the things that you did
but not so much about the result
and in a business setting in most cases
you want to avoid communicate like that
and the main reason is that
frankly the ceo won't care the ceo will
not care to whom you talk to
whose data set you analyzed these are
all just
details that in most cases are just not
of interest
but instead he will just trust you that
if you tell him something
of course you will have done the
research of course you will have done
the analysis but in general this
is just not the answer that c-level
executives of companies are interested
in let's contrast this now with a second
example of how
such a question could have been answered
and again let me just
read it out for you so here an answer i
could go like this our current
hypothesis
is that france would be the best fit for
our project
this is based on three reasons first our
consumer research shows that french
consumers will appreciate offering
second the competitive landscape in
france is not yet developed
we will be the first with this offering
third
our logistics and distribution
capabilities are
well set up to serve the french market
and now again let's first dissect this
what is special about this answer
so first this answer now doesn't talk at
all
about the little steps in between that
you talk to get to a result
instead this answer starts by giving
the result it starts by sharing your
current hypothesis
and so pretty much if the ceo would need
now to leave the meeting just after a
couple of seconds if you now would have
a
phone call popping up on his phone and
he won't be able to not continue
listening to you
he already just with the first sentences
of your answer
he would already know the result he
would already know what your hypothesis
is and of course now if you would have
the time to continue listening to you
he would not only have the answer but
you also would be able to hear the top
three reasons
that you based your conclusion that you
base your answer on
and this of course now is information
that the ceo
other senior eleven executives in the
corporation will be interested
in this is a type of communication that
is
top down it focuses on the content of
the results that you work
but not on the process this is exactly
what top-down communication is all about
and i would always encourage you to
communicate your results in this fashion
so why is it so difficult for many
people to on the spot
embrace this top down communication
skill and just communicate in that way
and probably this is for three reasons
first
it's just the natural way to talk about
it to use this bottom-up approach right
it's just
the order of how you did the things
first you did this then this then this
and this so this is just the natural way
of how you tell something but of course
still it's not the best way so only
because this is your first impulse take
a second take a step back
and just reflect the second reason why i
believe many people rather use
bottom up than top down communication is
because it really stresses
all the work that you did it shows all
your sweat
all the things all the long hours or the
mental energy that you put into a task
but the ceo
will not care how long you worked last
night or
how smart you were by coming up with the
idea of now hitting up the marketing guy
this is not what will interest the
senior level guys they will care about
the results so don't bore them with the
process
don't try to impress them with the long
hours that you worked and the third
reason is that people are messy in the
head
right people for themselves often do not
have it crystal clear why they are
recommending something
what the underlying reasons are when you
come up with a conclusion
with the recommendation so make sure
just also for the quality of the
thinking for the quality of your
documents that it's always crystal clear
for yourself just to start with what
really the result is that you want to
put out there
and what also the main underlying
arguments are that are supporting your
conclusions so i hope this video helped
you to understand what top
down communication is all about if you
have any more questions
on this topic leave me a comment below
in the comment section
and i will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you have
if you want to learn even more about
this type of professional communication
i have a book that i can really
recommend you the book is called the
pyramid principle logic and
writing and thinking it is written by
barbara minto she is an
ex mckinsey employee herself and this
book is one of the best sellers in
professional communication
if you want to check it out i included a
link to the book below in the video
description i can highly recommend it
and now if you want to do me a little
favor if you took
any value out of this video please hit
the like button
this really helps me with the youtube
algorithm and of course if you want to
see
even more content from me please
subscribe to this channel for more
content i release at least
one video every saturday if you want to
see even more content from me i also
have an instagram channel where i post
content almost every day my handle is
firm learning
if you want to read even more from me i
also have an email mailing list with
even more regular content on these
topics you can find a sign up link to
the mailing list below
in the video description thank you for
watching guys i very much appreciate
your time
hope you're enjoying a weekend and talk
to you soon again next
saturday